it's the nature of contagion is
relatively unusual the latency if I can
put it that way people you know we could
have the virus but not be exhibiting the
symptoms which makes it clearly more
difficult to isolate a potentially more
difficult to isolate and that has this
could have I should say a bigger
short-term effect in terms of activity
in areas where there is protection or
quarantine others there's very little
economic activity what we are picking up
with some of our bigger companies and
companies around the world that that is
spreading out through the so called
supply chain so when they use parts and
components to produce goods or for
example for Jaguar Land Rover and the
Midlands you know things that are
getting a little tight countless
examples of that that also slows down
activity there's less tourism we see it
on our streets here in the United
Kingdom that is you know if lower
activity as well it's hard to be you
know the direction it's hard to be
precise about the magnitude at the
direction is slower
yes direction is down it's hard to be
precise at this moment about the
magnitude and very importantly the
duration how long this will last your
anticipation is this will result in a
downgrade for UK economic growth well in
isolation we would expect that world
growth would be lower than it otherwise
would be and that has a knock-on effect
on the UK we're not picking it up yet at
all in in the UK economic indicators the
survey indicators or other things but if
the world's slower than otherwise would
be the UK's very open economy has an
impact but the most important thing is
to make sure the systems functioning
we're very confident about that and
we're on top of it do you think that the
UK economy comes structurally speaking
the economy is in a better place now
than it was when you took over or were
appointed in 2012 yes but and the yes is
that the improvements in the labour
market that had just begun very much
accelerated for a variety of reasons
real wage
is finally growing again in the last few
years so people starting to claw back
after a very difficult decade though
those are all the positives the bud is
that we like other advanced economies
but a little more so have had very weak
productivity growth effectively since
the crisis and that issue has not gone
away and it's in if anything the the
productivity challenge has deepened as
brexit had any impact there has it made
the economy structurally a better or
worse off place well it's it's too early
to tell you know I think the the new
relationships both with the EU and other
countries will be struck the economy
will go through a period of
reorganisation from EU focused to more
broadly focused that will have an impact
for a time well mr. Carney is stepping
down as governor next month he will stay
in the public eye working for the UN and
forest Johnson on the economics of
climate change contrary to some
campaigners he thinks this is an
opportunity to make money not lose it
can we have our cake and eat you know
can we get down to eliminate greenhouse
gas emissions while at the same time
having the same standard of living not
making sacrifices yes I mean there will
be changes but the simple answer is yes
we can and I think we have to be careful
in terms of what we're comparing the
measures that are needed in order to
move towards Net Zero was a result are
associated with huge swathes of
investment in the economy investment not
costs BP was pointed out a couple weeks
ago with their their change in strategy
huge opportunities in artificial
intelligence and advanced materials huge
opportunities in just the way Commerce
is organized all of those opportunities
are growth there are very very large
opportunities as you say and in fact a
number of CEOs number of people in the
financial sector we had an event at the
Guildhall and an uncle of them said
listen this is the greatest commercial
opportunity of our time because there's
a huge
opportunity to change the way we live
live better and not just in the UK but
around the world and that means UK
exports and that means better jobs and
higher incomes overtime is the era of
the superstar the rockstar central
banker / well was there an era I mean I
think because that was you
well it was probably something whose me
yeah what was Brett robbie williams i'm
star but i fade but serious point
governor just well i think the i think
in any there's a time where central
bank's assumed greater prominence and
importance just because of the
challenges I mean we had a series of
crises obviously the the so-called great
financial crisis wasn't great but a
series of euro crises other other issues
which were and it just pushed the
institution to the to the fore and then
the person who is leading the
institution you know it's always easier
to personalize thing and and so there's
that focus but it's but it it's a
success for central banking is when you
move towards the back pages money thank
you very much indeed
thank you